juan carlos was the king of spain for
very nearly 40 years a bridge between
the past pain of franco's dictatorship
and the modern world but now he's going
into exile
abandoning the country he once ruled it
is six years since he abdicated
handing the throne to his son felipe
what followed were growing
damaging allegations of corruption the
popularity of the monarchy has waned
juan carlos's reputation has collapsed
i'm a republican so in principle i think
it's great news
in any case it would be better if he
were judged
and if found guilty sentenced in a court
in spain
we think it's terrible because he's done
a lot for spain he's done more good than
harm
i know that if he leaves it's because of
everything that's been said but i don't
understand it
juan carlos came to the throne in 1975
he was seen as the king to make a break
from franco's cruelty
and embrace the modern world
six years later he was acclaimed as a
hero for standing up
to a military coup
for decades juan carlos was seen as a
stabilizing force in spain
but in later years he appeared out of
touch
he was injured hunting elephants in
botswana
while the financial crisis ravaged his
nation
and then there was this the late king
abdullah of saudi arabia
is alleged to have given juan carlos a
gift of around 100 million euros
in exchange for backing a business deal
swiss investigators have claimed the
money was hidden and later transferred
to a danish businesswoman
who was a close friend of juan carlos
she has now been asked to testify
juan carlos wrote today that he had
always wanted what is best for spain and
the crown
noble words but the legacy of this once
beloved king
seems tarnished terribly and the
question facing spain now is this
if criminal prosecutors think there is a
case to answer
will juan carlos come back willingly
adam parsons
sky news